I am here today to talk about why things
went south with with my ex oh god I
don't want to talk about how we met
because it's very like 21st century
first we started off on tinder and then
we just moved to Instagram DMS cuz a
little more classy we actually for the
first time ever we hung out we like
painted each other it was really weird
first date but it actually ended up
being amazing probably one of the best
first dates I've ever had I thought it
was great I was gonna go really well yes
I do there was a time we were like
sitting on this dock in Florida like
right on the river and then like out of
nowhere like three or four dolphins just
like come right underneath the dock and
like start swimming around I was just so
filled with happiness and love that
night I was just like a mess it was
great
I was like having my head like I'm
probably gonna marry her no one makes me
very outgoing and just more creative and
artistic we kind of inspire each other
well nothing like awful happened it was
very gradual I was in the college
lifestyle and then she was still like
home town I was upset about something
and no one wanted to go out to a party
and I was like I don't feel like going
to a party right now and he went anyway
and left me and then of course my
ex-girlfriends at the party and that
just made things even worse he felt bad
that I was upset about it but he didn't
really think that it was a big deal I
just left her in my room and like sounds
so horrible I don't know what I doing we
were on a family camping trip and I was
just kind of tired of his behaviors he
wanted to smoke and I was like please
don't smoke like we're literally on a
family camping trip why do you need to
smoke and I like just hit it like right
in front of her and like I didn't like
below
it sounds so terrible I'm not a bad guy
really I'm not that kind of environment
that he created was so uncomfortable for
me so I broke up with him over text yeah
I was mutual
I regret everything obviously like it's
you know took it for granted
let something really really really good
go we broke up and we didn't talk and
then I moved here and I knew that he had
the aspiration to live in New York but I
didn't know how serious he was or if he
was gonna go through with it but then he
texted me and he said hey I'm gonna come
up to New York I have an apartment I'm
gonna be there next week I was like oh
[ __ ] I feel like I don't I just don't
[ __ ] it up this time that's like my big
thing not to be all like mushy gushy but
I just proved to her like who I can be
like for her hello yeah how are you
doing I'm quite well how are you quite
well as well how about you interview I
was pretty good robust you know no
average yeah interview typical day no I
wrote a rap yeah and recorded it so
you're on soundcloud and you hear the
song you went just like a shark you'll
know that that was me know 3:00 in the
morning with auto-tune on my voice can
you guys tell me the story about the
party again you wanted to go out to a
Halloween party where two of his
ex-girlfriend's were also see I
mentioned one cuz I didn't want to sound
like an [ __ ]
yeah but then I was crying and I didn't
feel like going out anymore and you left
me there and went to the party and then
I went home by my side drove an hour
home but no home that night yeah bro I'm
the worst
so how did I resolve that how did I end
it you did it well had it what happened
I just got over it he's got over it
makes it sound so bad I'm sorry no I'm
sorry I'm sorry
it's okay I was talking to them about
how crazy it was that even when we were
broken up we ended up here so close to
each other yeah so is that a sign from
the big man or is it what is it what do
you think about that yeah it's very
strange do you think that me moving here
inspired you to get your [ __ ] together
oh yeah those people who get back
together like like every other two
months and stuff I don't think that's
necessarily healthy yeah I always said
that once we broke up that was it
oh me too and there was no because I'm
nervous going yeah I'm not the one to
keep going back and forth she told me
that we are not gonna like we weren't
gonna be friends she's not gonna be
casual with me at all either we're
dating and we're in love or were nothing
and I was just like like she's told me
specifically she's like I don't want to
be like your other ex-girlfriends
worried because he's very friendly with
all of his ex-girlfriend's not like
friendly but like no not in a bad way
but you're still friends with them yeah
and I wasn't gonna be friends with you
I'm not your friend and like like that
I'm not your friend
[Music]
[Music]
for more Latino content subscribe here